[Music]
if you are a chef right now and you
weren't able to work in restaurants what
would be your go-to career choice
YouTube and you still need to make money
on YouTube YouTube chef hmm I would sell
a cooking program for people you don't
know how to cook well I'm a professional
chef master class and here's 30 meals
that you can you know make that's one
meal per day I had a friend that uh she
started making a sushi rolls yeah
sorry delivering them to people so
she'll go to the grocery store buy the
whole ingredients and then she'll just
put on history on my hit me up with
whatever your orders you want catering
yeah so she became like her own post
mates best time that's cool I would have
trust in garnishing online coaching for
like cooking you know you webcam with
them teach them step by step you just
like alright now you got to put the meat
into the frying pan not quite but not
good job though you're over there
so just coaching them throughout the
whole time it's this is pretty bad in
the deceptions end of the call okay well
it turns out that a lot of chefs from
New York City's top restaurants are
actually being private chefs for
billionaires oh I was thinking about
that too yeah well I was I'm not a
billionaire but I was thinking about how
many hours I'm spending now just cooking
and cleaning I'm spending so much
[ __ ] time doing that right so I was
like how much does it cost to just hire
someone to come over but then I'm like
well that would be violating quarantine
well it depends on like these people
because sometimes they like stay with
them for a while sometimes the whole day
because they're like you're like I want
this at this time like they live in the
house see I'm not at that level
Orvis Joe Rogan Stolley every guest he
has he already has a doctor there that
test for corona and if he's passed
didn't he come and they do of the
podcast if not he sends him home but no
one has been sent home so far but he's
bald enough to have a doctor in his like
reception and he tests when the first I
come in but I'm not a billionaire though
my sister go hobby like can you even
live on can you spit in this too and
I'll be like I
thanks dude can you come back in three
days when I get the results yeah you
didn't get affected in those three days
I know yeah well yeah so they're saying
that a lot of chefs are like just
they're just cold calling billionaires
yeah billionaires or like talent agents
or real estate brokers seeing if there's
anyone that's down to hire a private
chef could you get the numbers one guy
knows a guy like the real estate or like
the telly tell an agent you know any
billionaires out there I'm out I need a
chef pretty much and so that's what a
lot of these chefs are doing is this is
actually a genius cuz there's a I think
there's a restaurant in New York someone
told me about him to call French Laundry
or something but it's like it's like one
of those top restaurants that it's
minimum six month to a year waiting list
so if you're a billionaire and you've
been wanting to eat here you don't even
have to wait anymore you could just have
this fool live with you and then did you
think you just make the whatever food
you want like imagine happening like
Jiro just make sushi for you when it
would have been a year's weight or
whatever you what would you do for fun
if you have everything in anything you
want it before we move there though I
did want to mention the seller because
that sounds like a good question okay
the salary of these I thinks is a sadly
no so they're saying that chefs who
choose to work in private homes they end
up getting about a twenty to thirty
percent pay raise as well as better
perks than working in a restaurant like
better hours and they also get to earn
between so they're saying usually it's
about a hundred thousand working at a
restaurant but working at with the
family it could be between 120 to 200
dollars a year oh wait 100,000 to
200,000 okay and and it's it's less work
but it's probably boring because think
about it you're like a nanny and you're
living is it breakfast lunch and dinner
you lose your steam but do you get to
use a tennis court there it depends on
what kind of family I end up getting
with because there's this one chef I got
interviewed for this article and he's
saying that during like being part of
the private chef thing like being a
private chef is inner
with the family that you get to stay
with and that you're cooking for and
getting to know them and stuff and
really seeing if like the personalities
and there's chemistry like we're like
that situation would even work out but
their palate is even up to par as kids
or some shitty macaroni and cheese again
god damn I'll [ __ ] slap the [ __ ] out
of my own billionaire kids give me a
raise
thanks for raising my children they're
saying that now that because of this
whole pandemic they need to be cooking
usually they'll be cooking in the home
with the family like I said trying to
like mingle and see if it works out but
now they have to be cooking in their own
homes to see if if this family would
like this chefs work and that's fair
okay this one particular has heard
horror stories where if you get paired
up with the shitty family like they'll
be verbally sometimes even physically
abusive towards the chef they try to
have sex with the chef give me some
scallops no scratch that
give me a [ __ ] lobster and let me
suck your dick like billionaires are
eccentric with the billionaires offering
to suck them yeah yeah yeah which one's
Hey
oh no cuz I was going back to my
original question of if you could have
everything in the whole entire world
what do billionaires do is they they end
up becoming philanthropists right like
to give big givers yeah
such langurs billionaires theory had sex
with everything that they weren't
supposed to
they even [ __ ] the cactus you know so
now they're like what else can I do well
I haven't sucked dick before and you
know what I enjoy sucking a [ __ ]
chef's dick because he doesn't even want
to get his dick sucked that's kind of
what I'm imagining is kind of like hey
you work for me now I'll give you extra
$20,000 tip let me pinch your nipple for
a second you know maybe the chefs like I
don't like this sounds too distracting
right folks my work here I'm just trying
to plug in make some bass sea bass this
what you spin my nipples
are you think he's hungry I'm just
wondering you know like what are the
what are the what are the odd job
stresses of working for these [ __ ]
that feel like they can do anything that
they want well that's what they're
saying though like for this one guy who
is saying that the these chefs like once
they agree to shelter in place like they
can't leave this home so if it's not if
it's not something that really works
with them then they're kind of stuck in
a really difficult position because they
need the money
they love to they love to cook right and
like that's their passion so they they
feel empty if they're not working and
yeah so like it's just and then the fact
that there's so many chefs looking for
these jobs that it's kind of like he's
not a billionaires to go around exactly
I feel like well billionaire they'll can
find so much so someone to do it no
matter what they'll put up with it
they're like I'm getting two hundred
thousand dollars I'll let them pitch by
no but that's the thing that's the thing
that sucks as the chef's like I have to
put up with this [ __ ] just cuz I'm
cornered to like you know restaurant
industry where you're like putting up
with the customers that the waiters the
other issue your boss he only asked you
all these people in the stresses where
it's like all put into one person or one
family one family yeah cuz then he was
also saying that it's it's really sad
not working in a restaurant because he
really loves that culture of like it
feels like a family and everyone like
you know you have your mentors or your
menteng mentoring someone else and
there's like constant hustle and bustle
and like you just feel like it's a team
back there yeah exactly it's all team
work and now you just have to cater to
one needy [ __ ] pretty much oh
man but what a fun story it would be
though if just working there and if
you're if it's if you just have to do it
why not we talked about the nipple
pinched me that's what half wondering
Sybil pinched billionaire I'm just
thinking of the worst nightmare I guess
getting my dick sucked in my nimble
pitched isn't the worst thing that can
happen and I mean it's not you won't
like worse than that it's like they're
they're berating you because of your
cooking skills or they call it food at
that's nothing cuz I cook you a chef and
like if I would I would love to get
trained by a Gordon Ramsay or like
warfarin yeah and he's gonna be
harassing you based off your food yeah
honored to be yelled at yeah dude if he
slaps me across his face put the [ __ ]
head of lettuce that I brought out
so be it I'm getting 200 grand baby I'm
getting feeling if the kids [ __ ] got
the food and threw it on the floor and
said it sucks and I have to get on my
hands and knees and eat it off of the
nice golden marble floor that they have
by all means I'm doubling my income and
I need to survive
I got no pride you know why cuz I'm a
[ __ ] businessman and the real dream
than like a worst-case scenario for you
or you steal [ __ ] I've got them back
I'll steal that [ __ ] I get paid good and
you know I'm doing the world a favor
because if I wasn't gonna do it someone
else would have to go through this and
one thing that could stomach the pain of
like these fools can audition the
billionaires - can't they like try out
different families to see if you're big
enough as a name right yeah I feel like
if you're a big Michelin star guy maybe
yeah like this guy comes from a
three-michelin-star restaurant he's a
sous chef yeah but I if they're
desperate for work and like they said
that there's an abundance of highly
trained chefs selection then the balls
in the billionaires court yeah I mean
cuz you have the option of going with
that family so it's like just put up
with it like if obviously it sucks but
it's like if you're desperate for money
and you don't want to be like I'm gonna
find a job anywhere else because you
probably still can
you're not scared which thing are we
putting up with the nipple pinching or
just a black male then black can do it I
just recorded and I'll [ __ ] me to
them you still do have an option
obviously you need the money and stuff
but if that's gonna be too much for you
then don't do it yeah nothing's worth
that humiliation and unless you enjoy it
our billionaires really that mean I
don't know I mean it means the way this
is a Glee huh I think it'd be their
family if anything cuz it's like they're
they grew up entitled and [ __ ] alright
yes okay like for a meal I've got to a
whole lot of different restaurants right
and
and there's rarely a time in fact I
don't think if visitor has ever been a
time where I've got my meal and said
this is unedible and I push the plate
away from me
we're not white yeah you're not you'll
eat everything
I bet to die cochlea Mario Park yeah
where it's like seven eight dollar ramen
right and we're eating and you know
sometimes with the ramen you could comes
with a side of like a pork belly over
rice or whatever this guy sits down he
goes excuse me but is the salmon wild
cut
this is $7.00 ramen like what do you
[ __ ] expect so there are people like
that out there that's [ __ ] weird it
doesn't matter about what your your
income bracket is yeah I'm just like if
you go into McDonald's no you're gonna
eat McDonald's you can't be like asking
if it's like I don't know some special
ass excuse me are the chicken nuggets
made from organic ethically sourced
chickens
free ranged yeah just like plants
it's a [ __ ] chicken nugget it's not
even chicken [ __ ]
they get it chicken they blend that
[ __ ] and in the use that comes
out he [ __ ] deep-fry back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]